[Music]
I'm action Ratan C and you're watching a
special season finale edition of going
underground no international or national
story in the UK is arguably more
dominated this season than allegations
that in March the Russian Federation
violated international law on British
soil the story has led to sanctions and
some of the worst London Moscow
relations since the end of the Churchill
Stalin roosevelt alliance joining me now
is the russian federation's ambassador
in London
ambassador Alexander Yakov anchor
ambassador thanks for coming on the show
why did Russia now it's a case of
killing since the press conferences you
gave over the summer
why did Russia kill a UK citizen first
of all I think the question is not
correct we didn't kill anybody in the
territory of the UK
unfortunately the Russian citizens Yulia
and Sergey scruple we're poisons as it
was reported by the British press and
since that time we didn't receive any
evidence what happened there but the
next day after the incident in Salisbury
the Prime Minister has made immediately
blamed Russia for doing this five months
passed since that time and we don't have
any evidence and the British authorities
are refusing to talk to us we cannot see
Sergey and Julia's people that's why the
British are violating the international
law the Vienna Convention and we're
really disappointed with the policy of
the United Kingdom on that violation of
the convention that you're alleging
there the British government presumably
think that their lives of the Russian
nationals will be put in danger if they
had consular resistance no because you
know we want to talk to them and
understand whether they are talking
under the pressure or not and this is
written in the Vienna Convention and the
convention is signed by the United
Kingdom so they have to fulfill its
international obligations okay it's true
that there's no conclusive evidence the
British ambassador is the u.n current
peer said your country has the means and
the motive that seemed to be
critical and the Foreign Office say that
when you when you when you speak against
these allegations you are engaging in
denial distraction and disinformation I
think this is a quite a misleading
statement because for example I want to
quote president of Czech Republic who
said that certain amount of so-called
Nova Chowk was produced in Czech
Republic and if you read the German
press you will find that most of the
labs in Europe are capable of producing
chemical weapons in small quantities so
basically the major argument of the
British government that only Russia is
capable of producing this kind of
poisons is simply is not correct but you
would I've been obviously we have Nova
choke here in Britain because otherwise
we wouldn't have it to be tested against
it's true that's exactly what we're
talking you know concerning in
connection with a portent lab but
they're denying that right but putting
down in fairness to the laboratory said
there they're continuing to refuse to
blame Russia former foreign secretary
Johnson and a few problems over that
what about the amount of novice work
that you have in Russia because there's
a deadline now the United States can
impose even more sanctions if you miss
this deadline on the OPCW being allowed
to come to Moscow to investigate your
chemical weapons program I stated
officially to the Foreign Office and
personally to Boris Johnson that Russia
never produced Navy chalk and we never
developed Navy chalk and for the ties in
the Soviet Union no it's in the Soviet
Union but Russia is the continuing state
that's why we took all the obligations
of the Soviet Union on us
I mean international obligations and
Russia eliminated all the chemical
weapons in October last year after the
all the procedures and by the way the
United States they still possess the
chemical weapons and they are delaying
and delaying the elimination of the
chemical weapons now it looks like that
they are planning to do this 2022 maybe
later
you see Brit
is now saying in our defense minister
Gavin Williamson says you are you are
responsible for aggression if here in
the Atlantic there has been significant
increase in Russian submarine activity
the Royal Navy is had to respond to
Russian warships approaching territorial
waters 33 times 2017 you're not
frightened of our defense secretary when
he says to you to shut up and go away
well actually no I would suggest to
compare the military budget of the UK
and Russia under the figures you know in
the report of the International
Institute of Strategic Studies in London
the budget the military budget year of
the United Kingdom is 56 billion dollars
and the Russian military budget is only
46 and who is aggressive what do you
make them if when the British government
says international leaders agree there
is no plausible alternative explanation
it is highly likely Russia was
responsible for this attack well we
prefer you know to do with the facts for
example if somebody comes to the British
Court you know he has to present the
case in in the situation with the
Salisbury nothing was presented we're
operating now with the mostly with the
leaks in the newspapers there are no
official statements and there are no
proofs and today the Foreign Office is
not answering to our diplomatic notes
with all the questions we send almost 60
diplomatic notes still no answers so we
don't have evidence and the British
government is not ready to present
anything to us and to the world
community perhaps they aren't producing
the evidence but according and I have to
say according to media reports media was
a big part of this story extradition
what did your embassy in London how did
it react when on the front pages of
Britain's newspapers it talked about an
extradition formally being made for
Russian suspects over the script well
first of all we we didn't know what
we're talking about because you know
there were no official statements the
we're leaks in the press and they were
talking about the two people alleged
the suspicions but we didn't get any
official requests and we will be here to
cooperate with the British side but we
want to see the evidence and we want to
see the proofs and we want to see
something that will support the British
position you have had low extradition
requests formally from the British
government Russian man no we don't know
even the names whom they want whom they
want to extradite well certainly no
leaks were admitted by the British press
the press report said the sources of
sources of course sources but nothing
has made sources I like it well we had
of course the Pulitzer Prize winning
exposure to My Lai massacre Seymour
Hersh Ron he said the people at the
Pentagon knew that this was nothing to
do with the Russian Federation per se if
it's not your government how do we know
it's still not under the aegis of your
government and it's the Russian mafia
they the people who got rich of the else
in years
very simple first of all five months
passed since the time of the accident in
Salisbury and we opened the criminal
case in Russia and we offered the
cooperation for the British to the
British just to understand maybe
together what happened there but so far
we we cannot talk to these free parties
we cannot talk to the doctors we cannot
talk to the people who work in Seoul in
Salisbury I mean in general where one
way or another engaged in the police
operation and of course nobody is ready
to talk to us in the important down of
course in this circumstance it's very
difficult to understand what's going on
here
there are widely reported stories by
mainstream reporters who may be better
connected than I am with the British
Secret Service's who say that Sergey
strip Isle would never want to come to
Russia because he was frightened of the
Russian state and now we hear that he
may have contributed to the famous steel
dossier which Donald Trump has been
fighting against him and arguably being
discredited
do you know anything about how Sergey
scribble was cooperating with the former
mi6 agent via Orbitz business
intelligence which was commissioned by
fusion GPS a problem I really have no
idea because following its no I'm
following but since I mean since the 4th
of March we counted almost a hundred
different versions in the media what
could happen what we know about Sergey
is crippled that he was a double agent
and he was sentenced for C years for six
years and he stayed in prison in the
Russian prison he was pardoned and he
decided to choose Britain to leave so
basically that that's the factual story
and he became the British citizen but he
didn't refuse from the Russian
citizenship because it could be done
only on a goodwill so basically he is
so-called he has the double citizenship
so that was his choice and this is where
we are as far as the different stories
in the media I'll tell you it says it's
so difficult to follow because the the
British media very is very good on the
only different stories ok but wouldn't
you expect the Russian security
apparatus to monitor vaguely people that
have been given the fact or asylum I
mean they live in echo is no he doesn't
she doesn't have any any problems with
the Russian law because you know he is
spent in prison for almost 70 years
and then he left for Britain you know
why we should have any problems with him
I have to say within the context of
Britain now considering spending 3
billion pounds on these new p-8a
warplanes to fight Russian submarine
activity how do you view these remarks
then which get what a wide currency here
in British political establishment that
well I'll tell you it's just
it's it's a certain military strategy as
I said fifty six billion dollars will be
spent and we see the British airplanes
you know in the Black Sea which is quite
far from Britain and from my point of
view it's it's a wrong policy wrong
military doctrine instead of developing
relations Britain is going to spend more
and more money on so-called deterrence
of Russia so this is the wrong way of
doing things were you surprised by the
attempt unsuccessful attempt by the
British government to get a UN
resolution about the fact that the OPCW
should now find who committed chemical
warfare Convention contraventions well
first of all I want to see that opposed
we opposed it because we we believe that
it doesn't reflect the substance of the
convention and it's not only Russia it's
almost half of the countries of the
signatories of the convention why is it
not fair to find out who committed a
violation of the Chemical Weapons it's
it's a fair story but this is the
prerogative of the UN Security Council
and instead of switching this let's say
activity from the UN Security Council
the switch to the OPCW it's a wrong
movement because this will undermine the
activity of the very technical
organization which is supposed to
collect the samples you know to make
certain conclusions but the political
decision who is guilty is the
prerogative of the UN Security Council
and we believe that the the United
Kingdom like a permanent member of the
Security Council should Council should
work in support of the UN Security
activity not by undermining its activity
I should just very briefly mention of
course the allegations of collusion as
regards our brexit referendum any new
allegations against your country that
you will now make you more wary of your
continual defense as an ambassador for
your interference in our brexit
referendum this is the favourite subject
of the mall
or the newspapers and I just want to
stay this for the record that Russia has
nothing to do with the choice of the
British people but I was always joking
that if you read the British press we're
in a good company with the Boris Johnson
ambassador Hager just stop you there
more from Russia's ambassador to London
after the break as well as riolu manager
Abdul Bari at one on some stories making
headlines around the world welcome back
we're still with Russia's ambassador to
the UK
Alexander Yakov an Co ambassador the
story of Syria seems to have left the
headlines in Britain Britain not
planning but not in the world
okay well certainly not planning to bomb
Syria in the near future but I hope
there will be no second Duma where
Britain violated the international law
with respect to what with respect to the
statements that there were some kind of
way using that the Syrian government
used the chemical weapon and that's why
Britain together with the United States
and France they pumped Douma and that
wasn't supported by the OPCW and all the
operation was staged by the white
helmets and it was documented and the
people who were part of the staging they
made a press conference in Hogg which
wasn't reported in the United Kingdom
but it was well reported in the world
alright Salah of the white helmets was
on this program told me it is the
Russian warplanes that are killing
civilians to resume says the Britain is
the second biggest humanitarian aid
donor in Syria of course some of that
money going to the white helmets and of
course the white helmets claim continued
Russian atrocities throughout this I
think this is a very misleading
statement first of all it's very
interesting that the white helmets
operated only in the areas where the
territory was held by the unknown and
the isis they never operated in the
areas where there was a moderate
opposition or the government forces so
that's where the aid was needed to
protect people from those Islamist
forces really yeah from did not from the
Islamist forces because you know and
they left Syria together with the
jihadists why not to stay now why not to
help the the the Syrian government they
say they had no choice because they were
reprisals by the Syrian government it's
not true the the let's say the the the
jihadis you know who laid down the
weapons they are not afraid
in the wild Helmand so afraid I think
this is some kind of a contradiction in
this well I understand that obviously
your boss the foreign minister lavrov he
was in Turkey to discuss Syria so
there's going to be a summit evolving
Russia Turkey German France Germany in
France
where's Britain in all of this a big aid
donor I know you're alleging there
that's a good question for the new
foreign secretary because the the
position of Britain is a little bit
different from the position of the world
community so we want to bring all the
refugees back to Syria and start the
normal life in this country so what the
British government is saying that first
we should start the political process
and then bring the refugees back to
Syria but the political process already
started and that's exactly what we are
doing in Astana in a some other place
including the Geneva so basically the
British government a little bit late
with its activity on bringing the
refugees I enjoy the inference of course
by the way France participated in the
humanitarian operation together with us
just a few weeks ago to bring you
humanitarian aid to Syria in a when I
asked my colleagues in the Foreign
Office whether they are ready to join
Russia and France on this humanitarian
mission I didn't get the answer well we
now against new realities sorry about
that
well the you well the u.s. certainly did
come up to scratch in supporting Britain
over the script I was putting on harsher
sanctions than Britain without any
evidence by the way when the minister
counselor was summoned to the State
Department and he asked you know could
you could you support let's say your
thesis was something tangible with some
kind of evidence and they told us they
cannot support and they stoled us this
is the matter of the national security
okay secret secret secrecy but we don't
know whether he discussed
with me obviously Britain has sanctions
too and we don't know where any of that
was discussed between the truck how you
can operate you know something that
you're hiding from the world I mean if
you have something in hands you have to
prove it all right you have to present
it and almost five months we have all
these conversations hundreds of leaks
and nothing in hands well given that
relations between London and Moscow so
poor we have to rely maybe on Trump
Putin talks and presumably we have to
rely on international law why not to
rely on the national law well Donald
Trump is certainly overseeing this
increase in in sanctions when it comes
to Turkey obviously British jets of
launched bombing missions for in chu'lak
airbase what is Russia as they as a
mainstream media here or american-made
you're playing at your s400 missile
defenses are terrifying the think tanks
within a mile of the studio and mr.
Dewan now saying this is I mean we have
Medvedev with the Russian Prime Minister
saying there's economic war coming from
these sections mr. Erdogan in Turkey
saying we may start looking for new
friends and allies and a lot of horror
here about a poll in the past 12 months
70% of Turkish citizens favorable to
political economic and security
alliances with Russia are you actively
trying to turn Turkey from being a
stable good NATO ally of Britons into of
course not of course not first of all
Turkey is our ally in the fighting of
the terrorists in Syria and I think they
took you made a great contribution you
know just to eliminate the jihadis from
Syria 96% of the territory is free today
this is first as far as the anti-missile
systems c400 they are simply better than
the American system and why not to
choose the best
[Laughter]
I'm just telling you we'll see that but
of course Britain is a contributor to
the AIB Bank it gave fifty million
dollars which may right raise some
eyebrows because I think you're talking
about the Asian thing yeah good the
BRICS
system as it were that is emerging a
country like Turkey it's gonna go to
Washington still rather than BRICS Bank
AIB China because it's China and Russia
that have appeared in the newspapers is
a big scary enemy to to Western Ejim
onic power do you think or do you think
bricks and AI abhi really had this
chance in the short term of being a
force in this world well I was always
against their politicizing the economic
relations unfortunately this is the
effect of the fact of today but speaking
about the financial capabilities of the
BRICS countries it's more than half of
the world and of course the economy of
China is bigger now than the economy of
the United States if we're talking about
in the purchasing power and by the way
you know that most of the projects that
were that were launched by Russia in the
European Bank of Reconstruction and
developing which is in London most of
them I mean all of them were stopped and
moving from London is moving from London
and so all this project moved to the
BRICS Bank so basically we want to
finance our activity now in Asia not in
Europe so this is just a fact of life
and this choice for there is for
everybody and any country could apply
we're now supplying in over the money
Africa Asia some other countries so why
because this Bank is not politicized
ambassador thank you
you